[Music]
yes bill you're us do exactly as I say
you'll make it out of this alive I
promise but to scream I love your face
right now
there's no time to explain
you want to die Jeff wanna face what is
it what is quantum creams then Reds time
Bert Bern's yeah from the time machine
Jeff from the time machine why aren't
you putting this on how do you think I
got here follow me
yes Dale oh okay on my mark three two
one okay
[Music]
chef that's one of you gotta take them
out what me I'm the brains you're the
Brawn remember by him he's just some guy
you want to get through that time
machine we gotta get through it there's
no time to explain
[Music]
[Music]
this calculator get the calculator okay
Oh
this is it I'll be going first that's
the time machine no it's a mini-fridge
yes it's a time machine Jeff wake the
[ __ ] up and get me inside I've started
to go 10 mins batch alright I'll see you
on the other side
no that wasn't right
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
what the hell is going on
Germans in the past 10 minutes burn time
no you need to tell me what that time
machine is you line across one kill me
it's a time machine it travels you back
in time and number two no kill this
friend no there's no time to waste
put this on why didn't you just at the
15 minutes back so we'd have five
minutes to talk
[Music]
[Music]
does that mean well yeah parents from
the past you what am i doing out here
don't you get it yet
Rogers characters in the video
everything you know is a lie Bri we'll
wait we're just pawns in their game we
gotta break out really well also those
are aliens we've got to kill them and
take their spaceship
come on now we gotta get the spaceship
[Music]
all right
you gotta drive one of these things
right let me guess
what are you doing man you're gonna hit
the button what button
today my job is to make my friends blow
up and I know that sounds weird but it's
not as weird as some of the things that
happen here there's no reason to risk a
man's life
[Music]
there's no time to explain
this is a serious beat what would be
really nice is to get some really
incredible hot and smoky
[Music]